هذه نقطة تفتيش عند مدخل
مدينة زاباريزا بشرق أوكرانيا ،
لكن هذا يوم غير عادي
فرضت فيه الحكومة
حظر تجول على مستوى المدينة أثناء النهار ،
ولا يُسمح بدخول أو خروج حركة المرور
، ونحن نلقي نظرة على
قوة الشرطة المحلية  حول كيفية فرض
حظر التجول الطارئ هذا ،
سأقوم بجولة في المدينة مع اثنين من
مفتشي الشرطة المحليين ، لقد مررنا
بالعديد من الجنود الأوكرانيين المنتشرين
لا يمكننا إظهارهم أو تصويرهم من أجل
سلامتهم أه نظرًا لوجود
حرب كاملة  يحدث في هذا
البلد ،
ما يلفت النظر حول حظر التجول هذا أثناء النهار
هو أن مدينة يبلغ
عدد سكانها ما يقرب من مليون نسمة أصبحت الآن
مدينة أشباح كاملة ، اسمي رومان
بانشان كرمان ، أنا أوكراني أخدم
في الشرطة منذ ست سنوات بالفعل.
أنا فخور بعملي
في إقليم المدينة ، فقط
رجال الشرطة وبعض العسكريين ،
كل سيارة تذهب إلى
المدينة متكسرة ، تقول الشرطة إنه من الأسهل
الحفاظ على الأمن والبحث عن
زميل روسي مشتبه به  السكان المقيمون عندما
يتم إغلاق المدينة ،
كم يبعد الجيش الروسي
الآن عن المكان الذي نحن فيه الجيش الروسي هو
عدة جبهات
ولكن أقرب مكان حيث
تم خلع الدبابات الروسية
ربما يكون
30 كيلومترًا من هذا المكان
على بعد نصف ساعة بالسيارة
نعم نعم أنت '  إعادة الحق
هل ستدافع عن الزاباريس إذا
أتى الجيش الروسي هنا ،
أعني أنك لست جنودًا ،
بل شرطة ، هل ستقاتل
أنا رجل ،
أنا رجل ، أنا رجل أوكراني
أما بالنسبة لي فهو أمر رائع جدًا.  يخجل من
عدم قيام الرجل بحماية أسرته وعدم حماية
منزله وعدم حماية
حياته ، يعرف الناس هنا ما حدث
للمدن والبلدات الأوكرانية الأخرى التي
تعرضت للهجوم من قبل الجيش الروسي ،
فهم لا يريدون حدوث ذلك
هنا ولكنهم  قل إذا كان الأمر كذلك ،
فهم جاهزون
إيفان واتسون سي إن إن زيفاريسيا أوكرانيا
لك